I'm just trying to trace the constellation
of where we started.
I think we've gotten off track.
I don't know.
Oh, have we?
I think we've gotten way off track.
It's so unlike us.
Anyway, Brian, what's your pick for 80s origin
story?
Well-
Why can't we stay focused like when we talked
about that time when the guy from Ferris Bueller
was the captain of the Enterprise B?
Tom, what are some of the 80s movies characters
that you think need their own origin story
films?
So as I was thinking about this, it occurred
to me that there's this whole family of characters
that sort of, as far as I can tell, they kind
of emerged during the 80s and we never got
an explanation as to why that was.
I'm talking about your Dirty Dancing's, your
Foot Looses, your Girls Just Got to Have Funs.
I believe it's Feet Loose.
Your Feet's Loose.
Your Attorney's General
Feet Leese.
Yeah.
In all of these movies, there's this one character
that just keeps popping up, and that's the
dad that does not want dancing to happen.
Oh.
The no dance dad.
You've got John Lithgow in Foot Loose.
The character just kind of keeps popping up,
and they're all around the same age.
I've got this theory that somewhere out there
in the creative abyss, there is an It Chapter
One where all of these dads were friends as
kids, and dancing happened to them in some
kind of a horrible way.
And now like 27 years later, they're being
forced to try and stop it before it reemerges
and becomes too powerful.
That's my-
Wow.
The anti dance crusade dads.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
That-
So Dirty Dancing and Foot Loose were the two
that I recall.
What was the third one you said?
Girls Just Want to Have Fun.
That's just the third one.
I feel like it pops up a lot though, right?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Generally, if there's a movie where somebody
wants to do dancing, they've got a dad that's
like-
There's someone who's like, "No, dancing's
bad."
IS there an anti dance dad in Flash Dance?
No idea.
I don't think she's talking to her dad by
that point.
No, I think she's-
She's already working in the steel mill.
Yeah.
That's true.
By day.
That's right.
But by night-
She's talking to her dad.
I don't know.
Yeah.
No, I support this.
Because then we get the origin story of Jerry
Orbach from Dirty Dancing, a character we
know almost nothing about who is also-
He's terrific.
He hates dancing and he loves his daughter
And he's a doctor.
Yeah, and he's a doctor.
He loves his daughter, but not so much that
he won't put her in the corner.
Yeah.
And he used to be-
No, he will put her in the corner.
He will.
And he's married to Emily Gilmore from Gilmore
Girls.
The guy said that nobody puts baby in a corner,
but he was empirically wrong because her dad
had done it five minutes earlier.
Yeah.
By the guy, do you mean Patrick Swayze?
I forgot the character's name.
Johnny.
The character's name was Patrick Swayze.
Was it Johnny?
Yeah, it was also just Patrick Swayze.
I was going to say Jack, but I was close.
Or Lover Boy.
Very close.
It has to be Jack.
Lover Boy?
Nope.
Well, that's how you call him-
It's Johnny Castle.
Yeah.
You say that three times in a mirror, he just
appears.
If only.
I wish.
Yeah.
Come on.
Bring him back.
I support this idea.
Sylvia, Sylvia, Sylvia.
Yeah.
Tom, I support this idea.
I'm done.
Who's next?
It's me now.
I am.
I'm next.
What are some 80s movies characters that you
want to see origin movies made for?
Great question.
Thank you.
So my favorite 80s movie by far is Ferris
Bueller's Day Off.
I think that's a lot of people's favorite
80s movie.
It's up there.
There's a lot of characters in that that could
have origin stories.
Sloan Peterson is super interesting when she
appears on screen.
But because everything's told through Ferris'
perspective, we don't learn about her as much
as you might want.
I don't know if I need Rooney's backstory
as much, especially considering.
But the one that I actually went with is I
want a Cameron origin story because I love
Cameron.
He is such a fully formed character.
You understand everything about who he is
from minute two of his time on screen.
You immediately are like, I get this guy.
But I want to know more about his weird museum
house, about this car situation.
I don't even know if I want it to be an origin
story, but maybe I just want to see the continuation
of Cameron rebelling against his dad.
See, continuation I'm 100% for, but it seems
like an origin story if Cameron is just watching
a kid get brow beaten for 16 years.
But I also want to see where all his hypochondria,
like if he just sat in his room and looked
through medical textbooks and was like, "Here
are all the diseases I have."
I feel like this kid created a lot of his
own neuroses just by himself.
Well, what about the day that-
This is-
What about the day that Ferris and Cameron
met?
That's a good one.
That's an interesting origin story.
That's a lot better than weird, dark, terrifying
thing that I'm describing.
How does a guy like-
I want to see-
How does a guy like Ferris-
I want to see why they're friends.
Yeah.
How do these two very opposite people-
Thanks for bailing-
... become best friends.
... me out of that Brian, I really appreciate.
You're so welcome.
That's what I'm here for.
Much like Ferris probably bailed Cameron out
of a lot of scrapes.
Part of this is just because, this would never
be possible, but I just love Alan Ruck so
much and he's one of my favorite character
actors working anything.
Captain of the Enterprise B, thank you.
He did a great job-
And also Connor Roy on Succession.
He crushed it-
No one watches Succession on this show but
me apparently.
... like five minutes later.
Now it's just Star Trek crosstalk.
I'm so sorry, Nina.
Nina, give us a moment.
This happens every show.
Every show this happens.
Yeah, sorry.
Anyway, yeah, okay.
Brian helped me with my fledgling non idea
and made it into a good idea, which is the
Ferris and Cameron friendship origin story
because I actually-
Now, see-
... think that'd be pretty great.
I love that.
I'm not against your original idea either.
I just think it's very-
It would just be so dark.
... Wes Anderson.
It's just this weird kid.
Well, that would have to be the director wouldn't
it?
Slowly getting weirder as time goes and more
afraid of everything.
Just-
Maybe I just identify with him way too much.
... having the soul sucked out of him.
I think we all do.
Yeah.
God, I'm getting more excited about this plan.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know what?
We can have both.
Why can't we have both?
Let's live in a world where we have everything.
It could be him writing in his journal about
the day his whole life went wrong, when he
met Ferris Bueller.
It's just like the whole thing's an extended
flashback.
Well, I was going to say, say you wanted to
work with that very weird fan theory that
Ferris is made up.
Figment of Cameron's imagination.
He's imagining him.
Tyler-
Oh, that could get dark.
Yeah.
So I took us-
Like a Young Sheldon situation.
I assume that's what happens in Young Sheldon,
right?
That's exactly what Young Sheldon is about.
I've never watched it but that's literally
the plot, yes.
Everybody is in Big Bang Theory is actually
in his head.
Well, I mean, yeah.
I don't know why they'd talk to him otherwise
to be honest.
Yeah.
Young Sheldon has a snow globe and it's full
of all of these sitcom characters.
Yeah.
If St. Elsewhere could get weird-
He has a snow globe and-
... and dark about child fantasies then why
can't Ferris Bueller's story?
I like the idea that that Sheldon has a snow
globe and inside is Johnny Galecki just creeping
around.
Inside is Howard Wolowitz.
Simon Helberg.
He says a Simon Helberg catchphrase.
I don't know.
I don't watch it.
I assume there's a catchphrase.
He's like, "I'm in a turtleneck."
Is that the catch phrase?
"I'm in a turtleneck."
It should be.
That's what happens on Big Bang Theory.
It's like, I was really good in Annette.
Who saw that coming?
He was in...
Oh, what was the name of that movie with Meryl
Streep and she was a terrible singer?
Florence Foster Jenkins.
He was-
Why do I know that immediately?
... amazing in that.
I was like-
Yeah, so he's amazing in Annette.
And it actually made me mad.
I was like, is that the guy from Big Bang
Theory?
What?
He's so good.
How'd he get so good?
Annette is like a weird French art house film
with Marion Cotillard and Adam Driver and
also a puppet, and then Simon Helberg being
really phenomenally good.
I took it personally a little bit.
I was like, this feels not allowed.
I'm just trying to trace the constellation
of where we started.
Yeah.
I think we've gotten off track.
I don't know.
Oh, have we?
I think we've gotten way off track.
It's so unlike us.
Anyway, Brian, what's your pick for 80s origin
story?
Well-
Why can't we stay focused like when we talked
about that time when the guy from Ferris Bueller
was the captain of the Enterprise B?
Exactly.
I feel like there's some subtle finger pointing
going on from Tom, and frankly, I won't stand
for it.
I'll go ahead and stand for it.
I'll take the opposition view.
We have an article up on looper.com called
Characters From 80s Movies who need their
own origin stories.
And there are a number of really cool ideas
in here.
I'm going to list a few of the ones that I
like, but we won't go into too much depth.
You mentioned Ferris Bueller, that's on here.
Did we mention Cameron in this one?
Was that the person that we mentioned in this
article, as I scroll down to the bottom of
the article?
Is he not even on here?
He's not even on here.
No, he's not.
That's-
We're going to cut this whole section.
No, he's not.
Yeah.
So anyway, I'm going to list-
I told you I was going off menu.
I'm going to list some of my favorites.
Because I was going to recommend...
I'm so sorry.
I'm scattered today.
I was going to recommend, since we already
talked about Dirty Dancing, Jennifer Grey.
Jeanie with Jennifer Gray.
Oh, that would be great.
Right?
Yeah.
What's the origin of her beef with Ferris?
How'd that all come about?
I'd like to see that origin story.
Man, that was a good decade for Jennifer Grey
as a whole, wasn't it?
It was is pretty much the only decade for
Jennifer Grey.
I don't know.
She's married to Agent Coulson from Marvel
so she's all right.
Oh, yeah.
No kidding.
She's okay.
Yeah, good for her.
Good for everybody.
Good for everyone involved.
Going back to Dirty Dancing and taking Patrick
Swayze and jumping off into Roadhouse.
That's one of the entries here, James Dalton,
his character from Roadhouse.
We'd love to see an origin story of how his
character became such a BA butt kicker.
You know what I would love out of that origin
story?
Actually, I would really appreciate that one
because I would like to find out if Roadhouse
was satire or not.
I have not been able to get a straight answer
from anybody my entire life.
It's not.
Was this tongue in cheek?
No.
Was this Adam West, Batman, but nobody smiling?
Right.
Or what-
No, the tongue-
What are we doing with Roadhouse?
... was not in the cheek.
This is just the-
I don't know what I like better, Roadhouse
or that time Chris Pratt described all of
Roadhouse on Parks and Recreation.
A show I'm bringing up again.
Other characters we have on here is Doc Brown
from Back to the Future, which I think I would
be interested to see a Doc Brown origin story.
But I almost feel like that might ruin some
of the fun-
Have you two seen that-
... I have with that character.
That is a John Mulaney bit I believe where
he's like, "Why is this disgraced scientist
friends-
Just hanging out
with this high school kid.
Can someone explain this?
That's another one.
It's it's like Cameron from the other.
Yeah.
It makes sense because so often, that's how
you start a hero's journey.
You have the character who is uncomfortable
and things have not been going well for them.
You get the born loser and then you get to
watch them win for the first time.
That's kind of who Doc Brown is before he
makes the time machine.
Right?
Yeah.
He's just this kooky scientist that has never
succeeded at anything.
And then he happens to succeed at inventing
time travel.
Yeah.
So again, this would just be decades of this
man failing at everything that he touches
until eventually he believes in himself so
much that he makes a deal with terrorists
to buy plutonium.
Because he-
It would be an interesting origin story.
... thinks he made a car that can travel in
time.
Again, that's super depressing.
It's like a Breaking Bad-
Yeah, but also like...
It's just-
I don't know.
It's like Breaking Bad meets Imitation Game,
like would watch actually.
Some other origin-
At the end like in Imitation Game, they could
say, "And today they call it a car instead
of a computer."
Anyway, go on, Brian.
Outstanding.
A couple other good entries here.
We got Marion Ravenwood from the first Indiana
Jones movie.
That would be-
I came close to picking that.
... really excellent.
That was good one.
You can cast Charlotte Ritchie who is on the
11th season of Taskmaster.
She's a British actress and she looks a lot
like Karen Allen.
Cool.
Nice.
We'll put up a side-by-side here so you can
see that they do look very similar.
We've got the perfect person to cast.
Perfect.
But you could see her early adventures with
Indy.
That could be interesting.
Lando Calrissian is on here.
We get a little bit of that over in the Solo
movie.
But for reasons we don't need to go into,
that's not really the greatest.
But there's two entries on here that I responded
to a lot.
One is David Lo Pan from Big Trouble Little
China.
Cool choice.
Big Trouble Little China is one of those movies
that I didn't see till relatively recently
in my life even though it's been around since
the 80s.
It was a few years ago.
It was on Netflix.
I was like, "You know, I've never seen this
movie.
I've heard the title a million times.
Why don't I watch it?"
I watched it and my mind exploded.
I was like, "Why is this the first time I've
seen this movie?
This is incredible."
I would love to see the origin story of David
Lo Pan.
I would love to see the origin story of literally
any of the characters in this movie.
Any one of them.
Good point.
What's Kurt Russell, Jack Burton, right?
Yeah.
I want to know how this guy became such a
confident adventurer despite being awful.
All of his adventures-
It's all in the reflexes.
Just his adventures that led him to the point
here, like how did Jack Burton become Jack
Burton, an adventuring truck driver?
He has the charisma of Kurt Russell.
That's how.
Just incredible.
Incredible.
That helps.
Yeah, it does.
And David Lo Pan, I want to know how did this
guy become this kingpin of crime in San Francisco?
I want to know how this weird, magical underworld
grew in this area.
I would be fascinated to learn all of this
stuff.
That's such a good one.
Yeah.
It's such an exciting concept to me that again,
it makes me mad that I haven't seen it.
And the other one that I really liked from
the list was Eddie Valiant from Who Framed
Roger Rabbit.
Yeah.
I love that one.
That was a really good one.
Yeah.
Hopping off of Doc Brown from Back to the
Future, now we're going Christopher Lloyd
over to our friend, Bob Hoskins playing Eddie
Valiant.
Now, this is a great, great, great, great
movie.
I know that it's cliche to say that, "Oh,
Who Framed Roger Rabbit, what a great movie.
Everybody knows that.
But it's the truth universally accepted that
it's a good movie.
Yeah.
But if you haven't gone back to see it in
a while, you're just like... again, I was
blown away.
I rewatched it pretty recently for the first
time in many years.
And I was just like, "This movie is so incredibly
good."
And part of it is because this guy, Eddie
Valiant is this fully formed character.
And so what's great about him-
Well, Bob Hoskins is such a pinch hitter.
He's amazing.
Super Mario Brothers, he's even good in that.
A movie that Brian loves.
Who wasn't good in that?
I love.
That's a whole other show.
I think the Super Mario Brothers movie is
extremely underrated.
The whole cast-
12 minutes later.
Brian, did you prepare a PowerPoint for this
episode?
I'll leave that to Tom.
I've been waiting for someone to bring up
the Super Mario Brothers movie.
Yes.
Oh, now that you mention it, click click.
No but-
It's funny.
You should say that.
But Eddie Valiant is this great character
who's haunted by his past, the tragic loss
of his brother.
You could even just have just one movie of
him doing a case with his brother.
It doesn't even have to be the one where his
brother-
So good.
... dies, and them interacting with the tunes
of the time and just kind of... it's just
this incredible world.
So who would you want to play a younger Eddie
Valiant, is my hot seat question?
I never think of the casting, and I'm so mad.
I'm trying to think too.
Chris Pratt seems like the natural choice,
right?
Yeah.
Chris Pratt would actually be pretty decent.
He would be pretty good.
Yeah.
He's charismatic.
I was just trying to throw some Mario shade,
but yeah, no, it would actually kind work.
Oh, I see-
Actually, legitimately, it kind of would work.
Yeah.
I see what you did there.
But it would work kind of well.
I think it would.
Here's-
I don't know why Jesse Plemons is popping
into my head, but he could do it.
Well, he could be the brother.
Oh, that's not bad.
But here's the thing-
He could be the brother.
Here's why it could work with Chris Pratt
or any comedy guy, because there's this great
photo.
They pan over all the photos when we're meeting
Eddie and he's asleep, he's drunk at his desk.
We're seeing the photos on his desk.
We're learning about his character.
One of the photos is him and his brother as
young kids with their dad and they're dressed
as clowns.
Right?
Perfect.
Yeah.
That's how at the end, right?
It's one of those setup payoff, right?
Right.
At the end, he juggles, he does the song and
dance.
If you haven't been paying attention, you
go, "How does this guy know this whole crazy
performance to get the weasels to laugh themselves
to death?"
It's because he was a clown.
So again-
That would be kind of nicely-
He used to love-
... full circle from Guardians of The Galaxy
where he uses a song from his mom's mix to
distract-
There you go.
Ronan.
Yeah.
It's all there.
It's all Pratt.
Chris Pratt feels like-
... too safe an answer.
I feel like maybe... oh, you know who would
be good?
Again, more Super Mario Brother stuff.
Charlie Day would be kind of good.
He would be great.
Just small-
Oh, man.
... and like-
Just the weird screwball energy.
Yeah, yeah.
Any time I want things to be really off the
rails, I'm like Charlie Day should be in it.
Wouldn't you want to see Charlie Day wearing-
Yes.
... a fedora, investigating crimes with a
bunch of cartoon characters?
You didn't even need to finish that sentence.
"Do you want to see Charlie Day," is all I
needed to hear.
But yes.
I definitely want to see him in a fedora,
solving crimes.
100%.
With cartoons.
It would be fantastic.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That is such a cool idea.
I want this movie.
I would love to see it as a TV series.
Yeah.
You don't necessarily even have to be building
up to the big payoff where Eddie Valiant's
brother dies.
You could just do this adventure series, like
a crime procedural but with cartoons.
And just-
... cartoons.
... watch these guys at the height of their...
yeah.
No.
That could be really fun.
Yeah, yeah.
It writes itself.
Oh, man.
They unravel mysteries.
Which network wants to pay us for this idea?
It would have to be Disney Plus since they
own the rights to Who Framed Roger Rabbit.
Okay, well does Disney Plus want to pay us
for this idea is my immediate follow question.
I would love it if they did, but I'm sure
that when it comes out, they'll be like, "Oh,
no, that was long in development before you
said anything."
Yeah, right.
"You fools."
That was a Russo Brothers original.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
It would be great though.
Yeah.
Oh, no, no, I'm changing my answer.
What's his name?
Okay.
Your guy from Philly.
What's his name?
Which one?
Come on, you guys-
Bradley Cooper.
My guy from Philly.
I wish.
Right?
Yeah, he'd be perfect.
Young Eddie.
And then Charlie Day could be the brother.
Nobody gets-
... young Bob Hoskins quite like Bradley Cooper.
Thanks for watch watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single video.
We love you.
Bye.